can you give me an example of this
inquiry process the socratic process and
then also why do you say that in your
approach it holds more of a preeminent
role than
meditation
okay i mean i see i mean i understand
meditation that's how i started myself
learning different kind of meditations
buddhism indian and sufi meditations
but um
the way my own experience opened up
is by
knowing my experience in the moment
and
being interested to understand it what
is it what is its meaning
what's it about where does it come from
so that becomes an inquiry into
uh
present experience meditation is not
focused on experience meditation is
focused like the concentration like i'm
with tibetan you visualize something
and that veda vedanta you say it's not
this not this
and i say no it's not i want to know
this what why is it here
what makes it be here what's it about
so i can start with any experience like
an experience of being irritated or
experienced of being
hopeful of something or experience of
inner joyfulness or experience of
sadness
and by and by getting into by feeling it
fully
as fully as possible which requires the
development of many capacities actually
because experiencing something fully is
not as simple as most people
can't experience things fully
most people experience things somewhat
mentally somewhat emotionally
fully i mean your your body is
sensitized completely open your heart is
open your mind capacities are open and
developed and all that
so
but you know there are degrees of
capacity for degrees of how capable we
are in engaging this inquiry depending
how open we are how developed we are
but it could begin in the simplest way
by saying well
today i'm feeling
somewhat um
discouraged
finding out why am i discouraged
i'm discouraged that's pandemic is never
over
ryan the scene goes from one thing to
another okay
i'm feeling just scary because the panda
but it's not really all
just the pandemic and fun
not just that
that is part of it but then i realized
i'm discouraged because i feel i still
don't feel completely fulfilled
you know i mean it's true there's a
pandemic i can't see
some of my friends and family but
there's something inside me that is not
complete
and then i inquire into what is this
feeling we're not being complete not
being fulfilled
now this talking back and forth to
oneself this reminds me of the
relationship a patient may have to a
therapist except one is having it with
oneself and i know that you've said that
you take plenty of inspiration from the
depth psychologist so is this what
you're referring to
well you see the psych it's similar
hasn't it similarity to psychology but
you see a psychologist
wants to heal the patient
here i'm not trying to heal some i'm
trying to understand it i'm interested
in knowing what it is
i'm not interested in getting rid of the
problem
and are you trying to understand it
without an emotion attached to it or are
you trying to understand it so that
you're happier or so that like what is
the emotion with the understanding are
you supposed to look at it as if it's
words on a paper so that is more
clinically are you supposed to identify
with it
neither of those
is complete engagement and it
you see that's the thing about
what brings my perspective of science
is that in
in the science
science you have to be detached from the
experiment you can't be
you know part of it the observer has to
be
uh
the more detached the more and engage
the more the experiment is pure you see
and the inquiry in oneself
it includes the subject the observer
so i'm inquiring in both the experiencer
and the experienced
you see they're both there in the field
of experience because and
so to to really because inquiring it to
oneself and inquiring into the subject
basically
and so as part of it is
psychological
part of it comes from the socratic
method if you remember socrates
would bring his
students and ask them
what's his courage
and he says i don't know let's find out
what is courage
why are they exploring courage not
because they want to be courageous they
want to first find out what it is do
they do i know it or don't i know it if
i know it what's it like
so that's that's a socratic part here
so it is not it's not aim
yeah it's not aim not aim-oriented
so because the
impetus
and this teaching
is not
the
or let's say the drive for enlightenment
is not a matter of being free from
suffering or from problem
but it is love for the truth
love to know the truth as completely as
fully as possible